is it really the end of the big budget
Sci-Fi series welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and Movie
[Music]
Channel thanks to the streaming Wars
we've had a little bit of a golden age
of basically Studio spending way too
much money on TV series we've been
getting shows like Star Trek which cost
what 910 million an episode on average
them spending 90 to100 million a season
we do have series like the foundation
that cost $45 million but Netflix
started this war basically by massively
overspending the new air bender series
which is coming out is going to cost $15
million a SE an episode basically so
$150 million for the season and and
obviously we've then got rings of power
but why do I say it's coming to an end
well the streaming Wars are over and
everybody
lost so look everyone all of the top
studios are now talking about how they
have to cut spending they've spent way
too much money and they've got to cut
back so I honestly don't think we're
going to be getting many more of those
hundred million series seasons anymore
Star Trek and all the producers over
there are talking constantly about how
particularly since the strikes nothing
is safe Mike McMahon very recently came
out and did an article basically talking
about his show lower decks and telling
fans to get behind it quite openly
really admitting that there might not be
a season
six he's saying no of the TV shows that
you love are safe right now everything
is up for consideration now this is a
video that I've been talking about
basically for the last couple of months
that even shows like strange new worlds
there are people at Paramount that don't
think it should continue there are
people at Paramount that think maybe it
should switch to a TV movie instead of
season 3 and that they should move on to
something new something simpler
something cheaper to
make so where does that leave us now
well shows like Foundation cost $45
million to make I think that is going to
be about the most expensive thing we see
in future that means you're not going to
see maybe the big names that we've seen
in some of the series we've had in the
past like to be honest Bard season 3
where a lot of the expense for that
series went on paying Jean Luke Bard's
wages we may not see very big special
effects things anymore and we may not
see as many t the adaptations of big
budget franchise things like rings of
power but we also just might see a lot
less
sci-fi now I'm going to be talking in a
video next pretty much about the shows
that now that the strikes are done and
the active strikes are nearly done that
we're hoping to get green lit we're
hoping obviously to get Stargate
something we talk about quite a lot in
this Channel and we're hoping to get a
few other
things but the age of the big sci-fi
even big fantasy series seriously might
be over or at least for a while when're
not going to be getting even series like
The Witcher again probably for a while
this is not just about the streaming
Wars though and how everyone lost it
this is also about the strikes the
strikes have really pointed out to
everybody that the Studios have been
spending too much money a lot of people
sometimes say oh look all these Studios
they're making a fortune give some of it
the writers and directors and actors and
everybody else and that's true to a
point but a lot of the studios actually
aren't making a lot of money Disney are
losing money hand over fist Paramount of
15 billion in debt HBO and their owners
are about 50 billion in debt it's not
going well all these Juds are actually
bleeding
money the stuff they're making costs too
much the audience is shrinking everybody
wants everything free through streaming
rather than paying for it we live in an
era at the moment to be honest where
people want everything free through the
internet they don't want to pay for
anything but they don't even want to
watch the adverts either so the Studios
have got to figure out how to make money
the same problem really is in the music
industry at the moment that everybody
wants everything through their
$9.99 Amazon music account and nobody
actually wants to buy a CD anymore so
the studio are basically just trying to
figure out how to pay and how to make
money in this new world the problem we
have is that big expensive TV shows like
sci-fi don't have the
audiences that they need so you imagine
you're a TV executive at the moment that
you're in charge of actually the money
the cost of things and you've got a TV
show like Star Trek that costs $10
million an episode and say a million
people watching or you've got a new
reality show that costs $100,000 an
episode to make and 2 million people
watch it which show are you going to
Green Light it will not be Star Trek it
will not be something that costs a 100
times more to make but actually doesn't
get the same audience even if your show
cost $100,000 to make but you only got
500,000 viewers half what Star Trek got
you would still go with the reality show
that costs so much less to make think
that's just business so I worry about
the future of really good quality
Science Fiction and Fantasy shows the
studios are skint the strikers have
actually now made that worse in a way
even though you know they got what they
deserved and they were 100% brilliant
for what they've done but they have made
things
worse and the future might be just a
little bit more reality show based we're
basically going back to what happens in
the mid 90s when everyone was skin then
as
well damn it guys what do you think
about my prediction that actually the
future might be a little bit duller
thanks to the streaming War and the
strikes do you think that we've had a
golden age of sci-fi and fantasy but
actually now we're probably moving into
the dark ages of sci-fi and fantasy or
actually there are enough big studios
out there like Amazon like apple who to
be fair to them spend their money a lot
more sensibly than Amazon that there's
enough of them out there that make
really decent sci-fi at the end of they
Apple do make decent sci-fi or are you
thinking the same as me the streaming
Wars have really been and gone now the
spending stupid money is been and gone
now and the future is probably going to
be a little duller get into the comments
and tell me exactly what you think if
you are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification it
really helps us out and you'll never
miss any of our new videos also you can
go to
[Music]